We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu Hi everyone, this is Roman Mars. I mean, this is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So I was out all last week at the TED conference.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内进行合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。大家好，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是说，这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。上周我一直在参加 TED 大会。
I gave a talk, it went great. I'll let everyone know when the video is released. I just had this amazing time, but I'm exhausted and I need a week off to recuperate. So the episode I want to re-broadcast is an old one, but it's a favorite mind. And I remembered it when I was being interviewed on the Ted Stage by Helen Walters. Here's the relevant section of the interview. So Roman, I suspect that you're a really good person to talk to at a cocktail party because you can come up with a really good rant
我做了一次演讲，效果很好。视频发布后我会通知大家。我度过了一段美妙的时光，但我精疲力竭，需要休息一周来恢复。所以我想要重播的一集是旧的一集，但它是我最喜欢的一集。当我在 TED 舞台上接受海伦·沃尔特斯的采访时，我想起了它。这是采访的相关部分。那么罗曼，我怀疑你在鸡尾酒会上是一个非常好的交谈对象，因为你能想出非常好的长篇大论
about whatever's on your mind. What is your other favorite design rant? Favorite design rant. I can complain about US money for a long time. What is it about US money? So that's what this episode is about. My problem with American money. It dates back a few years to when the show
关于你脑子里的任何事情。你还有什么其他喜欢的设计吐槽吗？喜欢的设计吐槽。我可以抱怨美国货币很长一段时间。美国货币有什么问题？所以这就是这一集的内容。我对美国货币的问题。这可以追溯到几年前，当时节目
was just a one-man operation. So I hope you like it. While I have you here at the beginning when the show was just a one-man operation, so I hope you like it. While I have you here at the beginning of the show, I have a couple of business items. First is that we have a survey that I'd love for you to fill out. It lets us know how we're doing and demographic data about who you are and what podcast you like. So it would really help us out. Go to survey-nerds.com slash 999. We'll also have a link on our website. It just takes a few minutes. I also want to give an extra shout out to some of the musicians who are
还只是一个人的操作。所以我希望你喜欢它。当我在节目开始时，节目还只是一个人的操作，所以我希望你喜欢它。当我在节目开始时，我有几个业务事项。首先是我们有一个调查，我很希望你能填写。它让我们知道我们做得如何，以及关于你是谁和你喜欢什么播客的人口统计数据。所以这真的会帮助我们。去 survey-nerds.com 斜杠 999。我们的网站上也会有一个链接。只需要几分钟。我还想特别感谢一些音乐家，他们是
regulars on 99PI. Keegan DeWitt, who I first discovered as the composer of the cold weather soundtrack, we use it a lot. He is brilliant. Okay, Akumi and all the artists on Hell Audio are fantastic. You cannot go wrong with them. The folks at Abandon Building Records in particular, I love the band set in sand and we use this song I'm talking over right now in the credits quite a go wrong with them. The folks at Abandon building records, in particular I love the band set in sand and we use this song I'm talking over right now in the credits quite a bit and everything I say sounds good on top of this song. And last but certainly not least, our pal melodian, who makes music that inspires me on a weekly basis. There are so many more and I'll remind you of them
99PI 的常客。基根·德威特，我最初发现他是《寒冷天气》原声带的作曲家，我们经常使用它。他很聪明。好的，阿库米和地狱音频上的所有艺术家都很棒。你选他们绝对不会错。特别是“废弃建筑唱片”的人，我喜欢“沙中布景”乐队，我们在片尾字幕中经常使用我现在正在谈论的这首歌，而且我说的每一句话在这首歌上听起来都不错。最后但同样重要的是，我们的朋友梅洛迪安，他每周创作的音乐都激励着我。还有很多，我会提醒你的
regularly on the website and at the end of the show from time to time. They all make great records, they're all on band camp. If you go support great artists like them, you will feel good in the world. We'll be a better place. Thanks. Now on with the show. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars.
经常在网站上和节目结束时。他们都制作了很棒的唱片，他们都在 Bandcamp 上。如果你去支持像他们这样伟大的艺术家，你会感觉很好。世界会变得更美好。谢谢。现在开始节目。这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。
US paper currency is so ubiquitous that to really look at its graphic design with fresh eyes requires deliberate and focused attention. So pull out a green back from your wallet or look at a picture online if you're in another country and just really take it in. All the fonts, the busy filigree, the micro-pattern. It's just dreadful. From a pure design, as point of view, it's, I don't know, that's tough because it is a little bit subjective,
美国纸币太普遍了，以至于要用全新的眼光审视其平面设计，需要刻意和专注的注意力。所以从你的钱包里拿出一张绿钞，或者如果你在另一个国家，就在网上看一张照片，然后真正地感受一下。所有的字体、繁忙的花丝、微型图案。真是太糟糕了。从纯粹的设计角度来看，我不知道，这很难，因为它有点主观，
but it's horrible. There's like eight fonts on this thing. Typographically, graphically, symbolically. If it'd never been designed before and someone was to submit that as a solution, I think they would just sort of throw it out. And I don't want to get too critical at this point because there are actually pretty compelling and understandable reasons for its particular brand of horribleness. But I think the primary tension embodied in the design of the Greenback boils down to
但它太可怕了。这东西上有八种字体。在排版、图形、象征意义上。如果它以前从未被设计过，而有人将其作为解决方案提交，我想他们会直接把它扔掉。我不想在这一点上过于挑剔，因为它的那种可怕确实有相当令人信服和可以理解的原因。但我认为绿钞设计中体现的主要张力归结为
how my friend Tom Nelson at the blog humans and design puts it. When I handle American money it feels like an artifact because it's so ornate and it has an old look to it. Even though paper currency itself, just the idea of money is a massive world-changing technology, the look and feel of US paper money is very stagnant. It seems like a relic from when our country was founded. Would you buy a car that would still look like the Model T Ford? No, you buy the latest model of it. Things evolve and change with time. That's Richard Smith. He runs a contest called the Dollar Redesign Project. It's become a classic, like classics do, through time and through usage and through familiarity.
我朋友汤姆·尼尔森在“人类与设计”博客上所说的话。当我处理美国货币时，它感觉像是一件文物，因为它太华丽了，而且看起来很旧。尽管纸币本身，仅仅是货币的概念，是一项改变世界的巨大技术，但美国纸币的外观和感觉却非常停滞。它看起来像是我们国家成立时的遗物。你会买一辆看起来还像福特 T 型车的车吗？不，你会买它的最新型号。事物随着时间的推移而进化和变化。那是理查德·史密斯。他举办了一场名为“美元重新设计项目”的竞赛。它已经成为经典，就像经典一样，通过时间和使用以及熟悉度。
So, it's awkwardness from a design point of view has kind of been superseded by its symbolicness. So if you were to start from scratch when we design US paper money, Smith says there are five major areas where we could improve. Number one is color. The idea of using one color doesn't really tell you much other than that we like the color green.
所以，从设计角度来看，它的尴尬已经被它的象征意义所取代。因此，如果我们从头开始设计美国纸币，史密斯说有五个主要领域我们可以改进。第一是颜色。使用一种颜色的想法并没有真正告诉你什么，除了我们喜欢绿色。
Our largely monochromatic money kind of baffles me. We've introduced a purple five and some peachy hues, but there are a lot of colors and most countries use at least some of them. Number two is size. Oh, why are the American currency, all one size. There's always been a question mark in my head and just never really made sense practically and philosophically.
我们主要是单色的货币让我感到困惑。我们引入了紫色的五美元和一些桃色的色调，但有很多颜色，大多数国家至少使用其中一些。第二是尺寸。哦，为什么美国货币都是一种尺寸。我脑子里一直有一个问号，而且在实践和哲学上从来没有真正说得通。
Having variable-sized coins certainly helps us sort them and you could use the same principle for bills, which leads us to point number three in Smith's manifesto. Functionality. Some functionality that enables people, if they can't see, to clearly distinguish on a very sort of fundamental level, which note is which. The fact that there's no easy way for the blind to use our currency goes beyond bad design,
拥有不同尺寸的硬币肯定有助于我们分类，你可以对纸币使用同样的原则，这引出了史密斯宣言中的第三点。功能性。一些功能使人们，如果他们看不见，能够在非常基本的层面上清楚地分辨出哪张是哪张。盲人没有简单的方法使用我们的货币，这不仅仅是糟糕的设计，
and it's actually immoral. Then the next fundamental thing I thought was composition. That's number four. Meaning like what it made from? This is a little sort of conception into like where this could go but you know it just seems that a product designer could come in and sort of come out with something really interesting. Recycled material with a smaller carbon footprint are more durable synthetics that last longer and at the very heart of the dollar we design project is number five symbolism. Who should go on the bills and why are the founding fathers? The be all and end all of everything that is America. And I think for me, that's one of the biggest issues
而且实际上是不道德的。然后我想到的下一个基本点是构成。那是第四点。意思是它是由什么制成的？这有点像是一个概念，关于这可以走向何方，但你知道，产品设计师似乎可以进来，并提出一些非常有趣的东西。具有更小碳足迹的回收材料是更耐用的合成材料，使用寿命更长，而美元重新设计项目的核心是第五点，象征意义。谁应该出现在钞票上，为什么开国元勋是美国一切的终极目标。我认为对我来说，这是最大的问题之一
if we were to change anything, I would say that would be where I would start. It could be a platform to celebrate everything that is unique, special, different that you didn't know about America. And that's the suggestion that can get a British expat on his way to American citizenship, like Richard Smith, some colorful hate mail. But it's an intriguing list nonetheless, even if you just view the five suggestions as a philosophical exercise to assess the current design for all of its strengths and faults.
如果我们想改变什么，我会说那将是我开始的地方。它可以成为一个平台，来庆祝关于美国你所不知道的一切独特、特别、不同的东西。这就是那个建议，可以让一个在去往美国公民身份路上的英国外籍人士，像理查德·史密斯那样，收到一些充满色彩的仇恨邮件。但这是一个引人入胜的清单，即使你只是将这五个建议视为一种哲学练习，来评估当前设计的所有优点和缺点。
It's hard to imagine all those things being modified on US currency, but it's not hard to imagine each of them being implemented somewhere. In fact, most of them are implemented everywhere. Case in point, Australia. On the other side of the world, each and every one of these five issues have coincidentally been addressed. Let me introduce a masterpiece of Australian design and technology. Australia's new $5 plastic note.
很难想象所有这些东西在美元上都被修改，但并不难想象它们中的每一个都在某处被实施。事实上，它们中的大多数在到处都被实施。以澳大利亚为例。在世界的另一端，这五个问题中的每一个都巧合地得到了解决。让我介绍一件澳大利亚设计和技术的杰作。澳大利亚的新版 5 美元塑料钞票。
I'm really proud of our money. I have absolutely no idea why I'm so proud of it, but I really am. That's Tristan Cook. And you're about to hear why he's so proud. Tristan and Tom Nelson here from Brief briefly at the top of the show, are user-centered designers, and they run a blog that I'm a big fan of, called Humans and Design. Tristan is Australian, Tom is American,
我真的为我们的货币感到自豪。我完全不知道为什么我为它感到自豪，但我确实是。那是特里斯坦·库克。你即将听到他为什么如此自豪。特里斯坦和汤姆·尼尔森在这里，在节目开始时简要提到，是用户中心设计师，他们经营着一个我非常喜欢的博客，叫“人类与设计”。特里斯坦是澳大利亚人，汤姆是美国人，
but Tom went to school in Australia for a couple of years, and the money there made a big impression on him. The money is plastic, and they're all different sizes, and they're colorful. At first, these changes were disconcerting. You'd all just look like toy money to me. But after Tom's initial shock, he began to appreciate all the different design characteristics of Australian currency.
但汤姆在澳大利亚上学了几年，那里的货币给他留下了深刻的印象。货币是塑料的，它们的大小都不同，而且色彩鲜艳。起初，这些变化令人不安。它们对我来说看起来都像玩具钱。但在汤姆最初的震惊之后，他开始欣赏澳大利亚货币的所有不同设计特征。
First is the color. $5 is sort of a lavender. $10 is blue with a little bit of a green stripe in it. 20 is... When you look at the ways you can tell the differences between things, generally it's called coding. That's a very simple human factors term for it. And you code through things like size, shape, feel,
首先是颜色。5 美元是一种淡紫色。10 美元是蓝色的，带有一点绿色条纹。20 美元是……当你观察区分事物的方法时，通常这被称为编码。这是一个非常简单的人为因素术语。你通过尺寸、形状、感觉来编码事物，
and color. So in Australian money, we have ours coded primarily by color, in some ways it's a better index because it doesn't require knowledge of who's on the bill, it only requires recognition of a color. Or an association with a pineapple or a lobster. It's not very common just yet, but we call our notes, cloker and names, but their colors and my two personal favorites are calling the $20 note, which is sort of an orange color, calling it a lobster, and calling the $20 note, which is sort of an orange color, calling it a lobster,
和颜色。所以在澳大利亚货币中，我们主要是通过颜色来编码的，在某些方面它是一个更好的索引，因为它不需要知道钞票上是谁，它只需要识别颜色。或者与菠萝或龙虾的联想。它还不是很常见，但我们称我们的钞票为“克洛克”和名字，但它们是颜色，我个人最喜欢的两个是称 20 美元钞票，它是一种橙色，称它为龙虾，称 20 美元钞票，它是一种橙色，称它为龙虾，
and calling the $50 note, which is sort of a green and yellow color, and calling it a piney, which is short for a pineapple. It's all about the piney's. Number two size. The bills are also different sizes as well, so they feel different in your hand. Sometimes when I've got a bit of cash in my pocket, I can tell the difference between a $5 note and a $20 note because of the feel. I would say that it's about a centimeter difference between each denomination, which between a 5 and a 10 is in that big, but between a 5 and a 50
并称 50 美元钞票，它是一种绿色和黄色，并称它为“派尼”，这是菠萝的缩写。这一切都是关于“派尼”的。第二是尺寸。钞票的大小也不同，所以它们在手里感觉不同。有时当我口袋里有一点现金时，我可以通过感觉分辨出 5 美元钞票和 20 美元钞票的区别。我会说每种面额之间大约有一厘米的差异，5 和 10 之间差别不大，但 5 和 50 之间
is very big. So you get like four centimeters difference. Both number one and two relate to the third issue raised by Richard Smith and that's functionality. You can see whether you've got a five, a ten, a 20, or a 50 from the top of your wallet. Because the color and size differences. Number four, composition. It's a thin sheet of plastic. The polymer notes were developed primarily to combat counterfeiting. It feels like plastic that you can fold and scrunch up. You can actually put it through the washing machine
差别很大。所以你有大约四厘米的差异。第一和第二都与理查德·史密斯提出的第三个问题有关，那就是功能性。你可以从钱包顶部看到你手里是 5、10、20 还是 50。因为颜色和尺寸的差异。第四，构成。它是一张薄塑料片。聚合物钞票的开发主要是为了打击伪造。它感觉像你可以折叠和揉皱的塑料。你实际上可以把它放进洗衣机
and it'll be fine. If you drop a note on the floor of a men's room, you don't really feel bad about picking it up and putting it under the faucet before you put it back in your pocket. These plastic notes cost more, but they last longer. They tend to last four times longer than fibrous paper notes. So you get notes in Australia that are 20 years old
它会没事的。如果你把一张钞票掉在男厕所的地板上，你真的不会因为把它捡起来并在放回口袋之前把它放在水龙头下冲洗而感到难过。这些塑料钞票成本更高，但它们的使用寿命更长。它们的使用寿命往往是纤维纸币的四倍。所以你在澳大利亚得到的钞票有 20 年的历史
and they pretty much just look the side. What Australia chooses to put on its currency is more in keeping with what Richard Smith of the dollar redesign project would like to see. It's much more inclusive and founding fathers and monuments, but it's hard to tell if these symbols are conveying much of anything to everyday Australians. They don't put statesmen on money frequently. There are artists and poets and I think there's some aboriginal leaders. If there's another thing to you could not pull prime ministers on our money. We don't have the reverence for prime ministers in Australia. But most Australians couldn't name the people that are on their money. I have absolutely no idea who is on any of our notes except for one side of the five dollar
它们看起来几乎一样。澳大利亚选择在货币上放什么更符合理查德·史密斯在美元重新设计项目中想要看到的东西。它更具包容性，开国元勋和纪念碑，但很难说这些符号是否向普通澳大利亚人传达了什么。他们不经常把政治家放在钱上。有艺术家和诗人，我想还有一些原住民领袖。如果还有什么东西，你不能把总理放在我们的钱上。我们在澳大利亚对总理没有那种崇敬。但大多数澳大利亚人说不出他们钱上的人的名字。我完全不知道我们的任何钞票上是谁，除了五美元的一面
note is the queen and that's just because I don't want her on there. I'd imagine if you asked any Australian if they know who is on their notes there would be less than one percent of people who could name anybody other than the queen. The symbolism in Australian cash seems to be tied more to the innovation of the bills themselves. There's a certain pride that polymer bills were developed in Australia and have been exported to the rest of the world. Australia now manufactures the polymer notes of nearly 20 other countries. It's a good business for them. The good design of the currency itself is the overriding brand.
钞票是女王，那只是因为我不想让她在上面。我想如果你问任何澳大利亚人他们是否知道他们的钞票上是谁，只有不到百分之一的人能说出女王以外的任何人的名字。澳大利亚现金中的象征意义似乎更多地与钞票本身的创新有关。有一种自豪感，聚合物钞票是在澳大利亚开发的，并已出口到世界其他地区。澳大利亚现在生产近 20 个其他国家的聚合物钞票。这对他们来说是一门好生意。货币本身的好设计是压倒性的品牌。
It's no ordinary note, however. It's Australia's new problem at $10 note. And it was developed and printed right here. I would like to see American currency redesigned and treated more like a living piece of technology rather than an artifact. I think even the most jingoistic among us could concede that there are design innovations that could be incorporated into US currency
然而，这不是普通的钞票。这是澳大利亚新的 10 美元钞票。它是在这里开发和印刷的。我希望看到美国货币被重新设计，并被视为一种活的技术，而不是一件文物。我认为即使是我们中最沙文主义的人也可以承认，有一些设计创新可以被纳入美国货币
to make it better, but there are some interesting reasons why we probably won't. In a someone once told me that getting rid of the greenback would be like burning the flag on the steps of the capital. That's David Walton. My name is David Walton, my book is The End of Money. A lot of people are currency is a physical touchstone of our national identity. Some of this is emotional, but there is this other concern that is simultaneously tantalizing and scary, I think. And that other concern is that when you redesign the money, you remind people what currency
以使其更好，但有一些有趣的原因说明我们可能不会这样做。有人曾经告诉我，摆脱绿钞就像在国会大厦的台阶上烧国旗一样。那是大卫·沃尔顿。我的名字是大卫·沃尔顿，我的书是《货币的终结》。很多人认为货币是我们国家身份的物理试金石。其中一些是情感上的，但还有另一个既诱人又可怕的担忧，我认为。而另一个担忧是，当你重新设计货币时，你提醒人们什么是货币
is and what gives the currency value. And of course, what gives the currency value is our belief that it's valuable and in the religious sense of it nothing more than faith or trust or worship whatever you want to call it makes a dollar worth a dollar or worth whatever you're going to buy with it. So that is upsetting to a lot of people and to maintain the aura of strength and stability of the United States economy. It probably helps to maintain these legacy features in the design of our money. Through what is now three or four generations,
以及是什么赋予了货币价值。当然，赋予货币价值的是我们相信它有价值，在宗教意义上，没有什么比信仰或信任或崇拜，无论你想怎么称呼它，更能让一美元值一美元或值你打算买的任何东西。所以这对很多人来说是令人不安的，为了保持美国经济力量和稳定的光环，在我们的货币设计中保持这些遗留特征可能是有帮助的。通过现在三四代人，
we've had the same color, I think, since the Civil War. The portraits, the engraved styling, the filigree, the legacy features convey stability. In our currency, the currency on which all other currencies are hitched has to be stable. So not only do we not redesign the stuff, but we don't pull older notes from circulation either. So we'll have reissues and redesigns of our cash, but you can still use the last generation design as legal tender.
我想自内战以来我们一直使用同样的颜色。肖像、雕刻风格、花丝、遗留特征传达了稳定性。在我们的货币中，所有其他货币都与之挂钩的货币必须是稳定的。所以我们不仅不重新设计这些东西，而且我们也不从流通中撤出旧钞票。所以我们将有现金的重新发行和重新设计，但你仍然可以使用上一代设计作为法定货币。
In other countries, a complete redesign deprecates the old design. You're given a grace period to use or exchange it, but after a certain date, the old currency is shredded by the central bank, and you can no longer spend any that you have left. This has never been the case in the US. You can even use an 18th century coin stamped with just the value of two cents to go buy something you might want to be careful because I could be so stupid. It could be worth $3,000 to a collector out there. But if you want to go spend it as two cents, you can. And again, this is part of creating this aura of super stability and inherent value of federal or reserve notes.
在其他国家，完全重新设计会废除旧设计。你会得到一个宽限期来使用或兑换它，但在某个日期之后，旧货币会被中央银行粉碎，你不能再花掉你剩下的任何东西。在美国从来没有这种情况。你甚至可以使用一枚 18 世纪的硬币，上面只印着两美分的价值去买东西，你可能要小心，因为我可能太蠢了。它对收藏家来说可能值 3000 美元。但如果你想把它当作两美分花掉，你可以。再说一次，这是创造这种超级稳定和联邦储备票据内在价值光环的一部分。
David woman is quick to point out that even though these concerns of instability have been cited when people bring up redesign in the money or eliminating the penny, he thinks it's pretty irrational and an overly cautious stance. It seems to me a little bit patronizing to think that Americans couldn't handle a dollar redesign. But really, who is going to push it forward? You know, if you're going to go to work in government, don't you almost buy definition and have some of that sense of patriotism and nationalism that would make you a little bit more inclined to
大卫·沃尔顿很快指出，尽管当人们提出重新设计货币或取消一分钱时，这些不稳定的担忧被引用，但他认为这相当不理性，是一种过于谨慎的立场。认为美国人无法处理美元重新设计，这对我来说有点居高临下。但真的，谁会推动它呢？你知道，如果你要进入政府工作，难道你不是几乎通过定义就拥有某种爱国主义和民族主义感，这会让你更倾向于
like the greenback as is and a little less inclined to, you know, let some RISD hot shots get after it. You know, let some Rizdi hot shots get after it. But still, primarily driven by anti-counterfeiting measures, US currency has been pushed to change in recent years, and most of these new disciplines are why it looks worse than ever. The legacy features remain largely intact, but a layer of modern fonts and swirls makes the bills look like they're busting at the seams. It's the worst of both worlds. You know, it's absolutely chaos. There's very little this elitum about our money from a design standpoint as far as I understand.
喜欢现有的绿钞，而不太倾向于，你知道，让一些罗德岛设计学院的热门人物去处理它。你知道，让一些罗德岛设计学院的热门人物去处理它。但尽管如此，主要是受反伪造措施的驱动，美国货币近年来被迫改变，而这些新学科中的大多数是它看起来比以往任何时候都更糟的原因。遗留特征在很大程度上保持完整，但一层现代字体和漩涡使钞票看起来像是要裂开了。这是两全其美的最坏情况。你知道，这绝对是混乱。据我所知，从设计的角度来看，我们的货币几乎没有什么精英感。
When I told David Woment about my new found discovery and appreciation of the Australian dollar as evangelized by Tristan and Tom. It was less than impressed. I don't think it's that remarkable. Congratulations to the Aussies and the scientists who came up with polymer banknotes. And I think they profited well because of that innovation. But I'm just not convinced it's a very world-changing kind of thing. It's pretty. Hey, I personally think pretty counts.
当我告诉大卫·沃尔顿关于我新发现的对澳大利亚美元的欣赏，正如特里斯坦和汤姆所宣扬的那样。他印象不深。我不认为它那么了不起。祝贺澳大利亚人和那些想出聚合物钞票的科学家。我认为他们因为那种创新而获利颇丰。但我只是不相信这是一种非常改变世界的事情。它很漂亮。嘿，我个人认为漂亮很重要。
But from his point of view, a better design bank note, even a plastic one, is still just a piece of paper. I mean, his book is called The End of Money After All. The design efforts out there related to money that excite me more are the design for the user interface of apps for mobile money, right? How are we going to be transacting with money and PayPal, mobile at Google Wallet, and where our designers bring into their on those interfaces? Because the interface with paper or a polymer money, I get it already. And the truly interesting frontier of design is not going to be
但从他的角度来看，一张更好的设计钞票，即使是塑料的，也仍然只是一张纸。我的意思是，毕竟他的书叫《货币的终结》。那些让我更兴奋的与货币相关的设计努力是移动货币应用程序的用户界面设计，对吧？我们将如何与货币进行交易，贝宝，移动支付，谷歌钱包，以及设计师在这些界面上带来了什么？因为与纸币或聚合物货币的界面，我已经明白了。而真正有趣的设计前沿将不会是
design is not going to be the bank note art that the Swiss come up with in 2016. Right? It's going to be the interface with mobile apps and what designers are doing to make our interactions with money more fluid, more sophisticated, and possibly got for really even like, wiser. You know, who's designing the apps to make us a little more careful with our money and how are they bringing to their sort of the principles of design to make that happen?
设计将不会是瑞士人在 2016 年想出的钞票艺术。对吧？它将是移动应用程序的界面，以及设计师正在做什么，使我们与货币的互动更流畅、更复杂，甚至可能更明智。你知道，谁在设计应用程序让我们对我们的钱更小心，他们是如何将设计原则带入其中来实现这一点的？
And this is something that Tristan and Tom are totally on board with. Physical money is probably on its way out. And polymer money as cool as it is is a technology of its time. They themselves have actually designed clever user interfaces so that the good aspects of physical money are retained and transactions feel more tangible and more real even when it's just bits flying through the air.
这是特里斯坦和汤姆完全同意的事情。实体货币可能正在走向终结。而聚合物货币虽然很酷，但却是其时代的技术。他们自己实际上已经设计了巧妙的用户界面，以便保留实体货币的良好方面，即使只是在空中飞行的比特，交易也感觉更具体、更真实。
So the physical US $20 bill will probably be gone from widespread use before it's a lovely shade of orangey red. I'm okay with that. Just as long as I have to see that wavy six-plag amusement park fond that says 20 USA in the background. I mean seriously, what the hell were they thinking? That fond is even cruel to Andrew Jackson, and that guy was a jerk. 99% of visible is now Sam Green's Man Katie Mingle, Avery Trollflin and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced at the offices of ArcSund. An architecture and an interior's firm
所以实体 20 美元钞票在它变成可爱的橙红色之前，可能就会从广泛使用中消失。我没问题。只要我不必看到那个波浪形的六旗游乐园字体，背景上写着 20 USA。我是说真的，他们到底在想什么？那个字体对安德鲁·杰克逊来说甚至很残忍，而那家伙是个混蛋。99%隐形现在是萨姆·格林的曼·凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特罗夫林和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，并在 ArcSund 的办公室制作。一家建筑和室内设计公司
who gives us a free home in beautiful and downtown Oakland, California. Support for 99% of visible comes from our fancy and filigree kickstarter backers including story worth. The easiest way to record your family stories and preserve them for generations to come find out more at storyworth.com. And from Hover, the best way to buy and manage domain names. If you have an idea, jump on way to buy and manage domain names. If you
它在美丽的加州奥克兰市中心为我们提供了一个免费的家。《99%隐形》的支持来自我们花哨和花丝的 Kickstarter 支持者，包括 Story Worth。记录你的家庭故事并为后代保存它们的最简单方法，请在 storyworth.com 了解更多信息。以及来自 Hover，购买和管理域名最好的方式。如果你有一个想法，跳上购买和管理域名的方式。如果你
have an idea, jump on it and make something out of it. The first step is buying a domain name. Hover makes it super easy and fun and if you're like me, you'll get even more ideas by registering those domains and then you'll register more, I think I might actually have the problem. If you have several dozen ideas rattling around in your brain, whisper them into Hovers ear, and they will set you up. They are your completely non-judgmental BFF, for crazy ideas at 2am. Go to Hovers.com to reveal your hopes and dreams to your secret Canadian component and use the Avocado game, and I'll save you 10% of your first purchase.
有一个想法，跳上它并用它做点什么。第一步是购买一个域名。Hover 让它变得超级简单和有趣，如果你像我一样，你会通过注册这些域名获得更多的想法，然后你会注册更多，我想我可能真的有问题。如果你的大脑里有几十个想法在乱撞，把它们悄悄告诉 Hover 的耳朵，他们会为你安排好。他们是你完全不评判的 BFF，在凌晨 2 点有疯狂的想法。去 Hovers.com 向你秘密的加拿大组件揭示你的希望和梦想，并使用鳄梨游戏，我会为你节省 10% 的首次购买。
That's Hovers.com. Support is also provided by Squarespace, the fast and easy way to create your own website, blog, or portfolio. Squarespace recently launched their latest version of their platform. It's called Squarespace 7, which has a completely redesigned interface,
那是 Hovers.com。支持也由 Squarespace 提供，这是创建你自己的网站、博客或作品集的快速简便的方法。Squarespace 最近推出了他们平台的最新版本。它叫 Squarespace 7，它有一个完全重新设计的界面，
integrations with getty images and Google apps, and beautiful, beautiful new templates. Try the new Squarespace at squarespace.com. It's free for two weeks, no credit card required, and when you purchase, enter the off-road invisible checkout, and I'll save you 10%. Squarespace, start here, go anywhere. And finally, we are made possible by Tiny Letter. Email for people with something to say. My boy, Maz Long, was that something to say? And three years ago, on this very episode,
与盖蒂图片社和谷歌应用程序的集成，以及美丽、美丽的新模板。在 squarespace.com 尝试新的 Squarespace。它免费两周，无需信用卡，当你购买时，输入越野隐形结账，我会为你节省 10%。Squarespace，从这里开始，去任何地方。最后，我们由 Tiny Letter 使之成为可能。为有话要说的人提供的电子邮件。我的男孩，马兹·朗，那是话要说吗？三年前，在这一集里，
he revealed what would be in his tiny letter. We basically talk about his robot and Iron Man suits and stuff. Robots and Iron Man suits and stuff. Not too much has changed, thank God. TinyLiter.com, it's free, easy, minimal, and powerful, the simplest way to send any mail newsletter. From the great people behind MailChimp. Thanks to MailChimp, the Night Foundation, and people just like you, we were able to create radio topia from PRX. Welcome to the Allusionist. That's Allusionist with an A, Notton I. This is Kremlin. Welcome. Welcome to Stringtru. To the Heart. The Truth.
他透露了他的小信里会有什么。我们基本上谈论他的机器人和钢铁侠套装之类的东西。机器人和钢铁侠套装之类的东西。没变太多，谢天谢地。TinyLiter.com，它免费、简单、极简且强大，是发送任何邮件通讯的最简单方式。来自 MailChimp 背后的伟大人物。感谢 MailChimp、奈特基金会和像你一样的人，我们能够从 PRX 创建 Radio Topia。欢迎来到《暗示者》。那是带 A 的暗示者，不是 I。这是克里姆林宫。欢迎。欢迎来到 Stringtru。到心脏。真相。
The Mortified Podcast. The Aerie of Everything. Radio Diaries. Love and radio. Fugitive Waves. From the Kitchen Sisters. Subscribe to the Mall at Radiotopia.fm. radio diaries. Palm slash 9.9, but I encourage you to explore the entire world of 99% invisible at 99podork. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《受辱播客》。一切的巢穴。《广播日记》。爱与广播。《逃亡的波浪》。来自厨房姐妹。订阅 Radiotopia.fm 的商城。广播日记。棕榈斜杠 9.9，但我鼓励你在 99podork.you 探索《99%隐形》的整个世界。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。